spargel stechen statt kicken das ist der
alltag der fußballerinnen vom sc sand in
oberkirch stehen die spielerinnen jetzt
regelmäßig auf dem spargelfeld und
ackern um ihr gehalt aufzubessern
bis zu 2000 euro bekommen sie eigentlich
pro monat wegen corona musste der verein
aus der ersten liga nun aber kurzarbeit
anmelden und bot seinen angestellten
einen nebenjob als erntehelfer an
und das obwohl der verein dank seiner
sponsoren wahrscheinlich sogar noch die
gehälter seiner spielerinnen bezahlen
kann
alle wollten run egal ob erste oder
zweite mannschaft oder mitarbeiter des
funktionsteams es war sehr wichtig den
bauern zu helfen weil eben auch keine
saison arbeiter- oder auch nicht in der
menge die sie normalerweise bekommen
nach deutschland kommen können und
deswegen war es uns sehr viel wert eben
hier den obst zu unterstützen einen
mannschaft also diese sommer zu beleben
weil in frankfurt aber nicht so viel
geld ist ich hoffe dass jemand uns hilft
wie wir heute
bisher wurden rund 250 euro verdient
wohin das geld geht ist noch offen
der dfb plant die
frauenfußball-bundesliga im mai und juni
zu beenden hat zudem das
lizensierungsverfahren gelockert
wirtschaftliche probleme oder gar
insolvenzen haben keine folgen für die
spielgenehmigungen auch punktabzüge wird
es nicht geben so sollte es der sc sand
als kleinster profifußball standort
deutschland schaffen
mehr kann niemand voraussehen wir wissen
natürlich nicht wie sich das entwickelt
wir haben natürlich viele firmen aus dem
mittelstand die uns unterstützen
ja da hoffen wir natürlich dass wir bald
den spielbetrieb wieder aufnehmen können
ab dem 20
april will cheftrainer sven thoß seine
spielerinnen wieder zum training
zusammen rufen
weiter ernten wollen sie trotzdem